prosecutors politics and personal
ambition that's the focus of tonight's
angle as a former criminal defense
attorney I saw my share of individuals
and companies caught in the crosshairs
of government investigators who
desperately wanted a trophy on the wall
we know the scenes you know a CEO
arrested and cuffed at his or her office
for all the employees to see for maximum
humiliation a prosecutor holding a press
conference claiming the evidence will
show that some high-profile person is
guilty of myriad crimes meaning jail for
the rest of his adult life it's all high
drama it's all like an episode of Law &
Order
now of course we need prosecutors to
help lock up the bad guys whether
they're white-collar criminals or
violent offenders and when they're
operating professionally I'm talking
about prosecutors and in good faith they
should be recognized for the public
service that they provide but long
before today's IG report was released
come on most of us knew that the FBI's
handling of the Clinton email and
Russian probes are textbook examples of
how cases should not be handled of
course the usual suspects spent most of
the day downplaying the findings of the
IG either because the IG found no
political bias
oh it's just run-of-the-mill
insubordination here we just got the
same kind of hammer you use to nail in a
painting on the wall the Hillary case
was properly decided on the law and that
that's the headline number one number
two no indication or evidence that
political biases it's deeply disturbing
that the Republicans remain obsessed
with undermining our intelligence and
law enforcement agencies okay nice try
man see but the IDS findings show the
opposite as we discussed earlier the
evidence shows that FBI director Jim
Comey operated according to his own set
of rules in the Clinton email
investigation quote
he admitted that he concealed his
intentions from the DOJ until the
morning of his press conference on July
5th and instructed his staff to do the
same we found that it was extraordinary
and insubordinate for call me to do so
we acknowledge that Comey faced
difficult choices in late October 2016
however we found it extraordinary that
Comey assessed that it was best that the
FBI director not speak directly with the
Attorney General in the Deputy Attorney
General like so many people in this town
he thought Jim call me that his title
gave him a license to ignore basic
prosecutorial protocols and no wonder he
wasn't all that keen on pursuing
Hillary's use of an unsecured server
given the fact that we found out today
that he himself was using a personal
gmail account to conduct government
business even Hillary referenced that in
a tweet today and if you like I thought
Call Me came off as imperious and
television interviews for that stupid
book of his
check out this tweet he said today in a
tweet I respect the DOJ IG office which
is why I urged them to do this review
the conclusions are reasonable even
though I disagree with some people of
good faith can see an unprecedented
situation differently I pray no director
faces it again thanks to I geez people
for hard work well he lost me at people
of good faith notice by the way how he
makes himself out to be the victim here
it's unbelievable
Comey should change his middle name to
hubris the man has learned absolutely
nothing from this experience and
remember by the way this is the guy who
signed off on three FISA applications
and didn't think it was necessary to
tell the FISA Court that Hillary paid
for the steel dossier this is the same
man who allowed Peter struck the FBI
agent to change the description of mrs.
Clinton's use of the private server from
grossly negligent
merely extremely careless so as not to
trigger the underlying criminal statute
but of course there was this breaking
news to compete with the IG release
today the New York Attorney General has
just announced a lawsuit against the
Donald J Trump foundation filed just
less than an hour ago a 41 page civil
complaint alleging that the Donald J
Trump foundation was actually an empty
shell New York's Attorney General is
suing President Trump and his three
oldest children alleging quote self
dealing and other persistent illegal
conduct that the president's charity I'm
sure this is all just a coincidence the
timing of this lawsuit come on against
the trunk foundation is beyond
suspicious now remember it comes from
the New York Attorney General's Office
consider the source disgraced former
attorney general of New York Eric
Schneiderman who you might remember sent
out a fundraising email right after the
investigation into the foundation was
opened he's a truly odious figure who
abused and humiliated his female victims
and then used his office and his
position to threaten them into silence
mark my words we haven't heard the last
of what he did to his victims and the
person who continues his crusade Barbara
Underwood who said upon taking over for
Sneiderman quote I believe this job at
this moment in history is the most
important job I have ever had oh yeah
little little subtlety there well think
about it Donald Trump operated a
foundation that had zero overhead no
administrative costs and gave away more
than 19 million dollars to a variety of
charitable causes Trump and his
companies personally poured eight
million dollars into the foundation now
there was a mistaken contribution made
to Pam Bondi's campaign but that was
rectified once it was discovered in
other words this is panning penny-ante
stuff that would never be pursued by the
New York State Attorney General's Office
if
Trump hadn't gotten into politics this
is yet another example of politicized
law enforcement an abuse of process this
time it was through a civil action on
the state level where were they by the
way at the federal level when the
Clinton Foundation was accepting funds
from foreign governments while Hillary
was Secretary of State
sometimes then wanted to get meetings
with Hillary meanwhile call me and his
political activists posing his agents
bent the legal standards for Hillary
Clinton allowing her to walk free and
they assumed that she was gonna be going
into the White House let's not forget
Clinton in setting up that private
server made up her own rules just as
Comey did in clearing her of any
criminal wrongdoing my friends this is
all a hideous perversion of justice now
FBI director Christopher Rae is
insisting there
IG report clears the FBI though of
structural responsibilities nothing
nothing in this report impugns the
integrity of our work force as a whole
chris ray I'm sorry you're wrong Chris
there are consequences the consequences
are that your fellow citizens question
whether or not they can have confidence
in the world's premier law enforcement
agency
remember when Jim Comey said this by the
way it makes me mildly nauseous to think
that we might have had some impact on
the election it makes me wildly nauseous
reading this IG report in learning how
Comey
and his colleagues intended to impact
the election and they failed and that's
the angle